la consommation de cannabis a augmenté
de 60 % chez les jeunes depuis 2007
selon une étude de l'inserm 24 % des
moins de 16 ans ont déclaré avoir fumé
au moins une fois par mois en 2011 et
plus de 40% des jeunes de 17 ans
interrogés ont déjà expérimenté le
cannabis
le cannabis est une substance que de
plus en plus de jeunes commencent de
plus en plus tôt et les jeunes
consomment en pensant qu'à voilà ça va
leur permettre de se détendre sera leur
permettre d'aller mieux
et malheureusement il ya tous les effets
secondaires après avec des conséquences
des choix irréversibles
alors pour en parler l'hôpital charcot
de saint cyr organise régulièrement des
réunions d'information ouverte au public
et aux personnels en contact direct avec
les adolescents en plus d'interventions
dans les collèges et lycées assurée par
la police nationale
y'a plus de cadre familial donc nous
policiers on essaye d'euros alors faire
comprendre justement puisque année
puisqu'il est au niveau judiciaire
donc on les regarde reçurent un sur les
interdits à toute personne en possession
de cannabis ou ayant consommé est
passible de dix ans de prison et des
amendes dont le montant peut grimper
jusqu'à plusieurs milliers d'euros sans
compter les risques pour la santé has
une troupe de la mémoire ou encore
cancer
d'une manière générale si un conseil à
donner faut éviter la répression
l'interdiction faut plutôt parler parler
dialoguer avec le jeune être signalé son
inquiétude vis-à-vis de cette
consommation cas le jeune et puis
essayer de l'emmener à consulter un
professionnel pour se faire aider
l'hôpital charcot organisent toute une
journée de sensibilisation sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin le 21
janvier prochain avec conférences et
tables rondes ouvertes au public